we begin this hour with the story of an
african country opening its arms to
black americans ghana's tourism minister
began encouraging african americans to
move there in 2019. as black lives
matter's protests erupted she said quote
you don't have to stay where you're not
wanted deborah patta spent time with one
american who chose to make ghana her
home
ghana's almena castle occupies a dark
place in america's history this used to
be a central trading hub where african
people from across the continent were
bought and sold into slavery now as the
us continues to confront its racist past
ghana is turning that history upside
down and welcoming black americans back
home you know i was living what people
would consider the american dream was
educated professional had friends i was
a socialite but i never felt safe
sonja davis was the epitome of
washington cool
connected successful a therapist trained
to deal with emotional health and yet
she was constantly looking over her
shoulder
there is just so much unrest davis
believes trauma is embedded in her dna
from the trans-atlantic slave trade to
the tulsa race massacre in 1921 where
some of her family were displaced i was
beginning to take a
an emotional and psychological toll on
me the trauma of racism is the trauma so
my immediate thought all the time was oh
my gosh you know what if a police
officer pulls me over am i going to be
physically safe
am i going to come out of it alive
then george floyd was murdered at the
hands of a police officer sparking
global outrage that demanded this black
life had to matter
i was barely holding holding on i could
feel myself nearing a nervous breakdown
and that's why i made the decision that
i had to get out of there
she had visited ghana in 2019 during the
government's year of return campaign
marking four centuries after the first
slave ship reached virginia it attracted
a record number of tourists aiming to
convert visitors into residence george
florid's name over there head of the
african diaspora forum erica bennett
said after the death of george floyd
they were inundated with inquiries
every day we get at least and this is no
exaggeration at least 300
people saying how can we relocate to
ghana about 5 000 african americans have
made the trip back to ghana and stayed
home is not a place
it's how you feel where you are the
feeling of belonging the feeling of
welcome
and a sense of freedom
and so just over a year ago sonja davis
traded her dc home for that sense of
freedom
it felt like a symbol for 2020
you know
i can't breathe
george floyd said and covert people
battling and
and here you are able to breathe no i'm
breathing yeah very much so
her therapy practice is now all online
and while she misses the convenience of
modern american life she's no longer
looking over her shoulder
i feel loved i lit i feel supported i
feel regarded i feel like i matter
i don't feel
like i'm looked at for the color of my
skin i'm just a person here that must be
liberating it
that is just the utopia of emotion
um it feels really good
and do you feel a connection to ghana in
terms of
the historical connection
it's interesting you asked that question
because i have been trying to muster up
the ability to go back to the slave
castle
slave castles on ghana's cape coast are
where many black americans are able to
trace the beginning of that awful
journey made by their enslaved ancestors
i thought i was ready
and
walking into the dungeon
i
i couldn't breathe
but i know i feel like i need to go
again
that was over a year ago
today she's ready to try again
walking in the shadow of horror
old pain is palpably present here
in these god-forsaken dungeons captured
slaves perished
only a third made it out alive
this sliver of light facing the atlantic
their last glimpse of home before being
pushed onto ships never to return
in all likelihood your ancestors passed
through here it's heavy it's really
heavy deborah i
you feel it though and it's made her
regard america differently
as black americans we're starting to
come to the realization of our place in
america
we're coming to understand that america
was really never meant for us to be
there
as free people in a sense that's why you
left america it's to reclaim yourself
exactly
exactly so i know that i am in control
of myself my destiny my dreams and
everything that i
want for myself and that my ancestors
wanted for me
and on a recent trip back to tulsa
she told them i went to the cemetery and
told them hey you know i made it i made
it out of here i made it back
i'm sorry
i made it back
i got out of here
it's brave
yeah
pusibies mornings
deborah patter elmina ghana
deborah patta thank you very powerful
story i've never been to ghana and i
started looking at that piece i want to
go
i don't know anybody any person of color
that hasn't had an uncomfortable
encounter at some point in your life in
this country because of the color of
your skin that said for me i i just
can't imagine for myself living anywhere
else but i understand what she's saying
and how she's feeling no that well as
you pursue
your piece of the american dream
if that comes at the cost of peace of
mind yeah oftentimes you start to think
about where else you could live and for
a black man in america you try to find
out where your roots are and i do feel
like even if you feel like um returning
to ghana isn't for you finding out your
roots is very important because in order
to know where you want to go you have to
know where you've been you have to know
your past that's for sure unfortunately
so many people really don't know their
past or understand history i mean
there's something we need to change too
the idea of returning has been
controversial since literally the days
of abe lincoln
and what to do
i think it's an indictment of america in
2021 that there are 5 000 black
americans who have already gone back to
ghana because they don't feel
comfortable here yeah what are we doing
wrong that we don't uh make them feel
welcome in this country for sure um but
it'll be interesting to see you can
understand how comforting and different
it would be to go from a place where you
are a black face among non-black faces
to be one of of all of men yeah yeah i
understood what she was saying it was
interesting 300 calls a day for people
asking about ghana yeah